السلام
عليكم صراحه شرف كبير جدا اني اكون متواجد
معكم اليوم في الرياض شكرا في البدايه على
حضوركم وشكرا للمنظمين على
[تصفيق]
الدعوه بعد فوز بجائزه روليكس لمشاريع
العالميه تشرفت بمقابله مستكشف حقيقي اللي
اصبح
لاحقا صديقي
ورفيقي الايطالي فرانشيسكو
ساورو في خلال لقاءاتنا واجتماعاته كنا
دائما نتبادل اطراف الحديث عن اكتشافاتها
العلميه واهتماماتنا
وابحاثه ولكن مره من المرات قال كلمه وشد
انتباهي بشكل رهيب
قال احنا ما نحتاج نروح للمريخ عشان نكتشف
شيء جديد او مكان جديد بالنسبه لي هذه
كانت صراحه
لحظه بديت اسال هل فعلا في
وجود التقنيات الحديثه مثل جوجل مابس او
الدرونز في اماكن في العالم لساعه لم
تكتشف بعد
اماكن بكر الى اليوم ولم يطاها قدم بشر
بالنسبه لي كان السؤال جدا
صعب ولكن بسبب هذا السؤال قررت اني ابادر
واشارككم في احد رحلاتهم الاكتشاف
العلميه واعرف هين هم بيروحوا ذهبنا
لاماكن فعلا بعيده عن ارض الوطن لم يلمسها
بشر قبل كده وكانت بالنسبه لي خبره جديده
احب اشارككم بعضها
دخلنا الى
كهوف في اماكن مختلفه في العالم ولكن
اليوم احبب اشارككم ب رحله لجنوب القاره
الامريكيه بين البرازيل وفنزويلا
دخلنا الكهوف كانت
غريبه
الرحله بدات بفري عن طريق اربع
قارات مده الرحله كانت في حدود ست ايام
متتاليه من السفر
المتواصل وللاسف ما كان كل الرحله على
طائرات تجاريه كبيره وفيرست ولا بزنس كلاس
كان اغلبها بطيارات عاديه طبعا وسافرت
كمان بطيارات صغيره
سسنا هذه الصوره بالذات
لطياره يعني كان
لي اكسبيرينس مميزه فيها سفرت في هذه
الطياره اربع ساعات ونص من السفر المتواصل
طبعا اللي يعرف الاستس يعرف ان الطياره
تتاثر بالرياح بدرجات الحراره يعني ممكن
خلال الرحله تقعد طول الوقت وهي بتلعب وهي
بتلعب بطني لعبه اربع مرات اعزكم الله
اغمى علي من كثر ما دخت في الطياره نص
ساعه صحيت بعدها قلت خلاص الحمد لله ك
شكلي نمتلي اربع ساعات طلت في الجي بي اس
لقيته لسه باقي ثلاث ساعات على
وصولنا للاسف الشديد هذا ما كانت التجربه
السيئه الوحيده مع الطياره في الحقيقه اول
ما جينا بنطلع على الطياره ركبنا جلسنا
على
الكراسي جاء الكابتن يبغى يشغل
الطياره الخرده هذه فشغل السلف الطياره ما
اشتغلت حاول مره ثانيه ما اشتغلت فاضطر
ننزل من الطياره عشان يرفع الكراسي اللي
تحتها البطاريه ويسوي لها اشتراك فخ
تخيلوا هذه هي الطياره اللي حتطلع فيها
وتسافر اربع ساعات
ونص هذه ما كانت الطائره الوحيده ولكن
ايضا بسبب صعوبه الوصول
لقمه جبل الاو تبوي اللي موجود في خلفيه
الصوره اطري نركب هليكوبتر وينقل معداتنا
وينقلنا احنا ايضا لصفحه الجبل الجبل عالي
جدا ارتفاع عن سطح الارض في بعض الاماكن
يكون اكثر من
متر و ماله اي طريق ممكن وصول عن طريق
السيارات ما في اي طريق معبد
او طريق ممكن الناس تسلقوا منه فالطريقه
الوحيده انه فعلا طيران عن طريق
الهيليكوبتر رحله مدتها تقريبا 45 دقيقه
احب اشاركم هي في 30 ثانيه اذا تكرمت
كنترول شغلنا الفيديو لو
[موسيقى]
سمحت
[تصفيق]
بعد ما وصلنا لصفح جبل الاوي
وشفت شكل
المخيم الوانه ساطعه
وجميله الاو تبوي هذا شكل الجبل وهو معروف
عالميا ان هو مقر اعلى شلال في العالم
معروف باسم الانجل وت
فول استمتعت
بضوء الشمس والجو الرائع لدقائق معدوده
قبل ما ابدا في رحله نزولي لمدخل الكهف ا
التسلق نزول وكان تقريبا ساعه ونص من من
التسلق النزول المتواصل الى ان وصلت لمدخل
الكهف وفعلا في هذه اللحظه فعلا ودعت ضوء
الشمس ودخلت للمجهول مشينا في ممرات كانت
غريبه وعدينا في اماكن وممرات كانت واسعه
وكبيره هذا مثال ب في الجزء الايسر من
الصوره حتلاقوا اوبجيكت لونه احمر
هذا شخص فلكم ان تتخيلوا حجم الكبير
للغرفه اللي كانت موجوده جوه
الكهف ولكن ايضا اضطريت امشي في مرات
ضيقه كان لازم ازحف من خلالها هذه صوره
سيلفي التقطتها احتفالا بعد ما قديت افك
الهلمت اللي ان عزقت في في الممر هذا طبعا
الهلمت ان عزق بعدها كتف ان عزق وسون
فالموضوع يعني فعلا ضيق وطلب مني زحف
تواصل الى ان اوصل ولكن كان فعلا ورثت
لانه وصلنا الاماكن كانت جميله
وغريبه تشكلات ما قنت اتوقعت اشوفها
بحياتي فعلا شفت قدره او قوه الماء على
تشكيل الصخور القوه اللي ربنا سبحانه
وتعالى اعطاها للماء عشان ينحت بها الصخور
على مدى ملايين من السنين وتطلع بهذه
الاشكال الفنيه
الرائعه
البيئه اللي انا كنت موجود فيها التشكيلات
الصخريه لبسنا الخوذ الاضاءه بيننا وبين
بعض
شكل التشكلات الصخريه فعلا كانت توحي انه
احنا ما احنا موجودين على كوكب الارض
تشكلات ما قد تخيلت اني انا ممكن اشوفها
او قد شفتها قبل
كده وصلت لاماكن كانت مزعجه بشكل خرافي
بسبب انهار تجري داخل الكهف وتسبب صد
وضوضاء هذا مثلا صوره اخرى
لشلال فتح فتحه اللي في سقف الكهف وسار
ينزل من
للكهف وارضيه الكهف هنا تملت بالمو بسسبب
الشلال هذا واكتف
ران ولكن وصلت ايضا
لاماكن كانت قمه في
الهدوء لدرجه انا كنت
ممكن حواسي بدات
تتلخبط فعلا من قمه الظلام والهدوء
عيني بدات تدمع بشكل غير
معقول بديت احس
انه عقلي يحتاج يسمع صوت صارت دقات قلبي
تزيد تبغى
تسمع اب فعلا كنت حاس ان في لحظه ممكن
اسمع دقات القلب من كثر كميه
الهدوء الحمد لله في خلال هذه الرحله
جمعنا عينات
من جبل كبير يتكون من ترسبات طينيه من برك
على سطحها كان في زي
الغشاء اللي اكتشفنا بعدده ان هي اصلا
ميكروبات عايشه على سطح البركه هذه ملايين
السنين
على ماده لزجه
بنفسجيه في كان شكلها فعلا غريب هذا
تشكلات ميكروبيه موجوده على جزء على صخره
واحده فقط في خلال اكتشاف للكهف ما قد
لقيناها في اي مكان ثاني هذه
برضو بودره شكلها لونها ابيض ولكن اكتشفنا
بعد ان هي ايضا مستعمرات ميكروبيه موجوده
تحت
الصخور انا قضيت داخل الكهف تقريبا اربع
ليالي خمس ايام نمنا
فيها دخلنا اماكن ما قد فعلا وطاها بشر
وكانت يعني عندنا ادله علميه تثبت هذا
الشيء لانه التشكلات الصخريه اللي تكون
موجوده على الارض تكون بعضها كريستالات
بسيطه وهذه الكريستالات جيولوجيا تحتاج
ملايين السنين عشان تتكون لان هي
ترسبات كنسي ششن
لمعادن موجوده في التربه وتحتاج وقت طويل
فلما تكون موجوده تثبت انه وموجوده بشكلها
الطبيعي ف ما حد مشي عليها وكسر عليها
واحنا فعلا خلال مشينا للاسف الشديد كنا
نضطر ان ندمر بعض من
هذه الترسبات ولكن في سبيل العلم ولكن
الشي الجميل انه فعلا احنا كنا نمشي على
اماكن احنا البشر الوحيدين اللي مشينا
عليها الكهوف هذه لها ملايين السنين
والحمد لله انه ربنا اكرمني انه انا صليت
داخل هذا
الكهف الفروض
ف مو بس انه الحمد لله كان انه العربي
الوحيد الموجود في الفريق البحثي ولكن
ايضا قدرت
انه امارس عباداتي داخل الكهف
بطريقه حسيت بروحانيه غريبه لانه المكان
فعلا تستشعر فيه عظمه الخالق عز
وجل ولكن في
المقابل العيشه داخل الكهف
النوم
الزحف المشي
التعب ما كان سهل كان فعلا تحدي نفسي
وجسدي
عظيم ولكن ايش السبب الاساسي اللي خلاني
اقوم بهذه التجربه والرحلات عشان اجاوب
على هذا السؤال اسمحوا لي اتكلم معكم عن
جزء كبير من حياتي
استغل اخر تقريبا عر سنوات من حياتي معظم
وقتي وجهدي
وتفكيري بعد اكتشافات بعد اكتشاف المضادات
الحيويه عن طريق البروفيسور الكساندر
فليمينج وبالذات عقار البنسلين اللي حصل
على جائزه نوبل
بسببه مضادات حيويه جديده بعدها تم
اكتشافها وهذا الشيء غير الطب تماما
ونقلوا الخطوه جديده ساهمت كثير في الحفاظ
على حياه الملايين من
البشر ولكن للاسف الشديد
اليوم البشريه مهدده من ميكروبات مقاومه
للمضادات
الحيويه واصبحت لا تاثر بالميكرو
بالمضادات الحيويه زي
السابق هذا الشيء هدد انه ينقل البشريه
لمرحله ما قبل المضادات الحيويه احنا الان
بنعيش في فجر لعصر
جديد تصبح فيل العدوه اللي كانت ممكن
نعالجها في السابق ما نقدر نعالجها بعد
اليوم بسبب الميكروبات المقاومه المضادات
الحيويه بسبب هذا الموضوع القيادات حول
العالم القيادات الصحيه حول
العالم ابدت اهتمامها ومبادرتها لمقاومه
هذا الخطر
التهديد فمثلا هنا انا احاول
اترجمها المدير التنفيذي لمنظمه الصحه
العالميه الدكتوره مارجريت شان قالت مرحله
ما بعد المضادات
الحيويه هي مرحله نهايه الطب بالشكل اللي
نعرفه
اليوم اصابات بسيطه بالتهاب في اللوز مثلا
او جرح في طفل في ركبه طفل قد تعود كما
كانت في الماضي من احد مسببات الوفاه احنا
اليوم ما نفكر في اهميه في هذا الموضوع
لانه فعلا بالنسبه ل للتهاب اللوز ما هو
شيء لكن في الماضي الى تقريبا قبل 80 سنه
او 90 سنه كان هذا
قاتل التقديرات تقول انه في عام
2050 10 مليون حاله
سنويا حتموت بسبب الميكروبات المقاومه
المضادات الحيويه هذا الرقم يعني شخص كل
ثلاث
ثواني سيموت بسبب الميكروبات المقاومه
المضادات
الحيويه
طبعا من خلال العشر سنوات اللي قضيتها في
الابحاث اتعاملت مع ميكروبات كثير بعضها
كانت مقاومه المضادات الحيويه
بشكل ذكي بحيث انها اصبحت
مقاومه لبعض المضادات بحيث ان ما نقدر
نكتشفها والبعض الاخر لقيت انه فعل مقاوم
لجميع انواع المضادات
الحيويه هذا كان
محور نقاشي مع فرانسيسكو في خلال اللقاءات
وفي خلال ابحاثنا وكان لازم نعرف كيف
الميكروبات هذه تطورت عبر الزمن عشان نقدر
نجاوب على هذا السؤال بشكل
حقيقي لازم نرجع بالزمن اللي ورا ناخذ
عينات من الميكروبات الموجوده في السابق
ونقارنها بالميكروبات الموجوده حاليا
ونعرف كيف تطورت البكتيريا للاسف الشديد
ما عندنا اله زمن نقدر نسافر فيها ولكن
عندنا الكهوف الكهوف هي نافذه للماضي نقدر
من خلالها نعرف التاريخ
وندرسه افترضنا علميا انه الميكروبات
الموجوده داخل الكهوف هي ميكروبات تمثل
الميكروبات الموجوده في الماضي بسبب عدم
تعرضها لمضادات حيويه جديده او
ل البشر ف ما تطورت من نفسها واصبحت
بالميكروبات اللي بنشوفها الان وايضا
الميكروبات الموجوده في الكهوف بتتعايق مع
بعض على مدى ملايين من السنين فبما انه
الميكروبات الموجوده في بما ان هذه الكهوف
لم تكتشف بعد قد
نكتشف مركبات كيميائيه جديده على هيئه
مضادات حيويه الميكروبات بتفرزها عشان
تحافظ على نظامها البيئي بدون ما تاثر على
جارتها الميكروبات
الاخرى وهذا ان شاء الله يساعدنا
على يساعد في حربنا ضد الميكروبات المقاوم
المضادات
الحيويه الشيء الثاني اللي انا احب
اشارككم فيه في هذه الرحله انه في اربع
دروس حياتيه تعلمتها واحب اشارككم فيها في
هذه الرحله تعلمت مدى اهميه
وقوه مهارات التواصل اذا انا وفرانسيسكو
ما استخدمنا مهارات تواصلنا وتكلمنا مع
بعض وشاركنا
افكارنا واستمرينا بالتواصل سواء وجه لوجه
او عن طريق الهاتف او عن طريق الايميل ما
ك وصلنا هذه المرحله من من
الابحاث الشيء الثاني اهميه تقاطع
التخصصات ومدى قوه تقاطع التخصصات انا
باحث بروفيسور مساعد في الاحياء الدقيقه
الطبيه بتعامل مع بروفيسور في
الجيولوجيا هذا الشيء تخصصين مختلفين
تماما
ولكن بدون ما نتعاون مع بعض ما نقدر نجاوب
على اي من
اسئلتنا اليوم للاسف الشديد احنا موجودين
في مجتمع فيله كثير من المشاكل اللي موجود
اللي تحتاج حلول وبدون ما نوحد تخصصاتنا
بعض ما ح نقدر
[تصفيق]
نساعدها الشي الثالث اهميه الخروج من
منطقه
الراحه اخذت لحظه فقط عشان اقرر افسخ
اللاب كوت النظيف حقي اخرج من المبنى
المكيف اقول مع السلامه لاهلي وبمناسبه
زوجتي موجوده معكم فاتمنى تدوها تحيه لانه
فعلا اشكرها هي واهلي ووالدتي ووالدي
واخواني على دعمهم المستمر واتجه لمرحله
فعلا صعبه
في لمكان غريب ما اعرف عنه اي حاجه وهذا
بالنسبه لي كان مهم جدا عشان اقوم بهذا
المبادره خروجي من منطقه الراحه والشيء
الاخير درس تعلمته منكم انتم استخدمت
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي عشان اوثق جزء من
هذه الرحله تفاجات وصدمت بكميه المتابعه
الموجوده منكم هذا الشيء علمني شيء واحد
اساسي انه مجتمعاتنا العربيه في حاجه ماسه
جدا لمحتوى علمي ممتع يساعدهم على فهم
المعلومه وفي نفس الوقت ممتع
لهم الجزء العلوي من الصوره صوري مع
اصدقاء اللي في اليسار جيمز كاميرون
مخرج فيلم تايتانيك هو ايضا مستكشف دخل لا
اعمق نقطه في البحر في الوسط براد نورمن
وكيفن هاند براد باحث للاسماك القرش وكيفن
هاند استرو بيولوجيست او عالم احياء فضاء
في ناسا و براين
كوكس استرو فيست او فيزيائي للفضاء الشيء
المشترك بين هذول الاشخاص كلهم انه كلهم
مشاهير علماء استخدموا وقت جزء كبير من
وقتهم عشان ينتجوا محتوى علمي وثائقي
يفيدوا به مجتمعاتهم ويبسطوا المعلومه
العلميه هذا الشيء اللي احنا نحتاجه في
مجتمعاتنا منن هذه المنصه انا
ادعو المنتجين والعلماء
والمستثمرين
انهم يبادروا وينتج محتوى بهذا الشكل
واتمن هم انهم يخدموا هذا الشيء شكرا لكم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
جميعا